>>> HI, EVERYONE, I'M AMARA
WALKER IN TODAY FOR KATE
BOLDUAN.
WE BEGIN WITH BREAKING NEWS.
POLICE HAVE MADE AN ARREST IN
CONNECTION TO THE MURDERS
INVESTIGATION OF FOUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS IN IDAHO.
TWO FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOURCES TELL CNN THAT THE FBI
TOOK A SUSPECT INTO CUSTODY IN
NORTHEASTERN PENNSYLVANIA.
THE ARREST COMES NEARLY SEVEN
WEEKS AFTER THE STUDENTS WERE
FOUND STABBED TO DEATH IN A HOME
NEAR THE UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO
CAMPUS.
POLICE IN MOSCOW, IDAHO, WILL
HOLD A NEWS CONFERENCE LATER
THIS AFTERNOON AND CNN'S
VERONICA MIRACLE IS LIVE IN
MOSCOW, IDAHO, WITH THE VERY
LATEST.
VERONICA.
>> Reporter: WELL, AMARA, AS YOU
SAID, THOSE FEDERAL SOURCES
TELLING OUR CNN'S JOSH CAMPBELL
AND MARK MORALES AN ARREST HAS
BEEN MADE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT AT THIS POINT
IT IS A MAN IN HIS 20s BUT
BEYOND THAT THERE ARE VERY FEW
DETAILS COMING OUT AT THIS HOUR.
I DID SPEAK WITH POLICE THIS
MORNING WHERE THEY SAID THERE IS
GOING TO BE THAT NEWS CONFERENCE
AT 1:00 P.M. TODAY.
THEY WOULD NOT TELL ME ANY
FURTHER DETAILS, BUT JUST FOR
CONTEXT THIS IS THE FIRST PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAS HELD IN WEEKS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE OBVIOUSLY A MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT THAT ARREST BUT IT HAS
BEEN NEARLY SEVEN WEEKS SINCE
THE MURDERS HAPPENED HERE AT
THIS HOME BEHIND ME AND YOU CAN
SEE ACTUALLY TODAY ANOTHER
MONUMENTAL DAY HERE AT THE CRIME
SCENE THAT HAS BEEN VERY
RELATIVELY QUIET OVER THE PAST
FEW WEEKS.
THERE IS A CLEANUP CREW HERE
CLEANING THIS HOUSE TODAY AND
IT'S GOING TO BE EVENTUALLY
TURNED BACK OVER TO THE PROPERTY
OWNER, AND SO WE UNDERSTAND THAT
SO MUCH IS HAPPENING HERE IN
MOSCOW AND THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
MAKING THIS BIG ANNOUNCEMENT
TODAY, AND IT ALSO COMES ON THE
HEELS WHEN TWO FAMILIES ARE
GOING TO BE HOLDING A
CELEBRATION OF LIFE THIS EVENING
IN QUARTER LANE, IT'S ABOUT AN
HOUR AND A HALF AWAY FROM HERE,
NORTHERN IDAHO, MADISON MOGEN
AND KAYLEE GONCALVES, THEY WERE
THE BEST OF FRIENDS, THE
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN PLANNING THIS
FOR A COUPLE OF WEEKS NOW.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HOLDING IT
AT A LOCAL CHURCH AND CERTAINLY
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT FOR
THE FAMILIES TO BE DISCUSSING
TONIGHT, AMARA.
>> I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING
THIS STORY FOR WEEKS NOW.
CAN YOU TALK TO US ABOUT JUST
HOW THIS -- THESE MURDERS HAVE
IMPACTED THE COMMUNITY, HOW
WE'VE GOTTEN TO THIS POINT AND
ALSO THE FACT, YOU KNOW, THAT
INVESTIGATORS HAVE BEEN QUITE
TIGHT-LIPPED ABOUT ANY NEW
DEVELOPMENTS SO THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, A HUGE
DEVELOPMENT THAT WE'RE HEARING
TODAY.
>> Reporter: CERTAINLY COMING AS
A SHOCK BECAUSE AS YOU SAID,
THEY HAVE BEEN SO TIGHT-LIPPED
THIS ENTIRE TIME.
NEARLY THE FULL SEVEN WEEKS
THERE HAS BEEN VERY LITTLE
INFORMATION RELEASED, AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY SOME OF THE
FAMILIES, AT LEAST ONE OF THE
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN VERY
OUTSPOKEN, THE GONCALVES FAMILY
FRUSTRATED WITH THE LACK OF
INFORMATION BUT THE ENTIRE TIME
POLICE WERE TELLING US AND THE
PUBLIC THAT THEY HAD STRONG
LEADS, THAT THEY HAD A LOT OF
INFORMATION COMING IN AND THAT
THEY WERE TRYING TO KEEP THE
INFORMATION CLOSE TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
THIS HAPPENED, AGAIN, SEVEN
WEEKS AGO, FOUR STUDENTS
MURDERED.
THE CORONER SAYS THEY WERE
LIKELY MURDERED IN THEIR SLEEP.
SOME OF THEM HAD DEFENSIVE
WOUNDS AND SO IT APPEARS THAT
THEY WERE TRYING TO FIGHT OFF
THE ATTACKER.
IT HAPPENED IN THE EARLY MORNING
HOURS AFTER A NIGHT OF PARTYING.
ONE COUPLE, XANA KERNODLE AND
ETHAN CHAPIN WERE AT A PARTY AT
SIGMA CHI FRATERNITY NOT FAR
FROM HERE WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE AND THE OTHER COUPLE,
MADISON MOGEN, KAYLEE GONCALVES,
THE BEST OF FRIENDS WERE OUT AT
THE CORNER CLUB, A BAR IN THE
AREA.
THEY ALL CAME BACK HERE AND WERE
ALL HOME BY AROUND 2:00 IN THE
MORNING ON THAT EARLY SUNDAY
MORNING, AND WHAT HAPPENED
BETWEEN 2:00 A.M. AND NOON WHEN
THE FIRST 911 CALL CAME IN,
WELL, THAT IS STILL A MYSTERY
BUT WE HOPE TO LEARN MORE TODAY
AT THAT PR